Hallo Deutschschule. Wörter mit den Umlauten “ä”,“ö”, “ü”.
Der Käse.
Ein Toast mit Käse.
Der Käsetoast.
Zum Frühstück esse ich einen Käsetoast.
Das Olivenöl.
Das Olivenöl für den Salat.
Das Olivenöl ist sehr gesund.
Ich benutze das Olivenöl zum Kochen.
Benutzt du auch das Olivenöl zum Kochen?
Der Baum, die Bäume.
Die Bäume sind grün.
Im Wald gibt es viele Bäume.
Die Bäume produzieren Sauerstoff.
Die Möwe.
Die Möwe liebt den Strand.
Am Strand gibt es viele Möwen.
Die Möwe fliegt gerne über das Meer.
Die Nuss, die Nüsse.
Die Erdnüsse.Die Walnüsse.
Die Kokosnüsse.
Das Eichhörnchen liebt Nüsse.
Liebst du auch Nüsse?
Der Apfel, die Äpfel.
Die Äpfel sind rot.
Die Äpfel sind sehr gesund.
Die Äpfel hängen an dem Apfelbaum.
Die Bäckerei.
Der Bäcker arbeitet in der Bäckerei.
Der Bäcker backt eine Torte.
Ich hätte gerne ein Stück Käsetorte, bitte.
Ägypten.
In Ägypten gibt es Pyramiden.
Die Pyramide.
Köln.
Köln ist eine Stadt in Deutschland.
In Köln steht der berühmte Kölner Dom.
Der Löffel.
Der Löffel zum Kochen ist der Kochlöffel.
Der Kochlöffel.
Der Koch kocht mit dem Kochlöffel.
Der Schlüssel.
Der Schlüssel für die Tür ist der Türschlüssel.
Der Türschlüssel.
Ich schließe die Tür mit dem Türschlüssel auf.
Das Büro.
Das Bürogebäude.
Ich arbeite im Büro.
Die Süßigkeiten.
Viele leckere Süßigkeiten.
Im Supermarkt gibt es vieleleckere Süßigkeiten.
Die Wüste.
Die Sahara ist eine Wüste.
In der Wüste gibt es Kamele.
Der König.
Der König trägt eine Krone.
Die Krone.
Der Föhn.
Der Föhn föhnt die Haare trocken.
Ich föhne mir mit dem Föhn die Haare trocken.
Die Möhre.
Die Möhre heißt auch Karotte.
Die Karotte.
Möhren sind gut für die Augen.
Isst du auch gerne Möhren?
Der Rüssel.
Der Elefant hat einen Rüssel.
Der Elefant benutzt den Rüssel zum Essen.
Süden.
Norden, Osten, Süden, Westen.
Spanien ist im Süden von Europa.
Die Bücher.
Die Bücher stehen in einem Regal.
Das Bücherregal.
Ich lerne Deutsch mit den Deutschbüchern.
Wie lernst du Deutsch?
Der Zahn, die Zähne.
Die Zähne putzen mit der Zahnbürste.
Die Zahnbürste.
Ich putze mir die Zähne mit der Zahnbürste.
Das Gemüse.
Im Supermarkt gibt es frisches Gemüse.
Brokkoli, Paprika und Mais sind Gemüsesorten.
Die Rüstung.
Der Ritter trägt eine Rüstung.
Die Ritterrüstung.
Die Ritterrüstung schützt den Ritter.
Das Känguru.
Das Känguru hüpft.
In Australien gibt es viele Kängurus.
Hast du schon mal ein echtes Känguru gesehen?
Abonniere den Kanal der Hallo Deutschschule
und aktiviere das kleine Glöckchen.
Wenn dir das Video gefallen hat,
dann gib uns jetzt einen Daumen nach oben.
Und in dieser Playlist findest du weitere
Videos zum Deutsch lernen.
Klicke jetzt auf diese Playlist.